[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
kevin mcguire and andrew pierce they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages
the guardian writes pm accused of
corruption as rules on sleaze torn up
the sleazy way out reads the front of
the metro as mp owen patterson avoids
suspension
the eye also leads with a former
minister caught lobbying for companies
paying him a hundred thousand pounds a
year
the front of the yorkshire post follows
the fallout of gary balance's confession
that he used a racial slur against a
former yorkshire teammate
a telegraph headlines nhs staff won't
have to be jabbed this winter they say
this is despite christmas lockdown fears
the financial times leads with the
federal reserve saying that it will
begin scaling back its 120 billion
dollar monthly bond buying program this
month
and the sun leads with an exclusive on
channel 4 stars conundrum
and we're joined tonight by kevin
maguire and andrew pierce well
one word across many of the papers and
that is sleaze let's start with the i
uh andrew with you toys rip up britain's
anti-sleaze rules to save guilty mp
just talk us through what happened today
it's an extraordinary position for the
conservative party to find itself in um
the
owen patterson a former cabinet minister
was accused and found guilty if that's
the right word of an egregious breach of
the rules about lobbying uh this he he
was found guilty of that by the
parliamentary commissioner woman called
catherine stone now a lot of tourists
think she's very party pre and very pro
the labour party very anti the tories
but this was then investigated her
report was investigated by the standards
committee 14 people seven lay people all
party they unanimously found that owen
patterson had broken those rules and
recommended that he be suspended for 30
days now what the tories have done today
they say uh they don't like the way the
report was reached they don't think owen
patterson was given a fair hearing and
so they effectively passed an amendment
pausing that suspension of 30 days and
asking and setting up a completely new
system of investigation it's a bizarre
way to behave it looks like the
perception is that many tory mps voted
to try to prevent owen patterson being
suspended now andrea ludson dame andrew
ledson who tabled the memory said that's
not what it's about if he's guilty if
the new committee finds him guilty he'll
have to be suspended but i'm afraid
that's how it looks it looks like the
toys have changed the rules because they
don't like the way they affected one of
their own and it's amazing nearly a
hundred conservative mps abstained and i
think 13 or 14 voted against so this is
deeply deeply this is causing a lot of
concern on the tory benches and a lot of
tory mps were very unhappy that they
were whipped into supporting this
amendment because this is a
parliamentary matter this is a house of
commons matter this shouldn't be
something that number 10 or the whips
get involved in this should be something
nps decide for themselves it's about the
power of the commons not the executive
not number 10 sticking its nose in it's
a very unedifying day i think for the
conservative yeah three-line whip but it
it passed by a narrow majority of just
18 at kevin
what do you make of this is this the
tories rewriting the rule book for one
of their own
well it feels like that it's exactly as
the eye say and andrew said it's
extraordinary as bizarre i mean it's
outrageous it's contemptuous and i think
boris johnson will come to regret uh
what's happened as will owen patterson
but there we are the eye tories rip
about his sleeve rules to save guilty mp
the public backlash will be absolutely
enormous because people will imagine
themselves at work in a situation
somebody's done something wrong and all
of a sudden the boss class changed the
rules to protect them now sleaze did for
the john major conservative government
in the 1990s back to basics and so on
wave after wave sleazy
allegations got hammered um what's
changed here is it's boris johnson
leading the charge against the the
sleaze has been questions raised about
his own conduct not least the finance uh
of his flats redecoration but here it
does appear as if he is protecting one
of his own and people will not like that
and quite rightly will not like that
i've read the report into own paths it's
very long it's but it's very detailed he
gets 82 000 pounds a year as an mp he
wanted another 112 000 pounds from two
two other jobs he was lobbying and
advocating for those companies which is
not allowed under the rules it is
clearly and absolutely banned but that
is what he was doing he's
refused to accept responsibility for all
the way very sadly his wife
took her life
he's claimed the inquiry was partly uh
responsible for that um
people are mourning grieving it's very
it's very difficult uh to go into that
area but
his his business dealings were were
dodgy and they were wrong
uh and maybe he just can't face up to
that and accept it and the consequences
of uh perhaps of of
of what he did but for the for the
conservative party for boris johnson or
the government the cabinet to change the
rules like this to protect one of their
own he's absolutely outrageous because
the only way the system can work as if
it has cross-party support it isn't
partisan
tomorrow a labor mp uh one of the
leicester labour mps claudia webb will
be sentenced
uh after she was uh convicted of uh
threatening a woman who was a friend of
a
of her of her boyfriend uh said to have
threatened to throw us in their face
release uh embarrassing photographs of
this woman to her
um
to her family now
i'm on i'm on the left andrew's on the
right but i think we would both agree
that claudia webb is unfit to be an mp
whatever the sentence she is given
tomorrow because of the nature of the
the crime she is said to have committed
in the court fund she she committed but
owen patterson 30 days suspension he
should have taken it because he clearly
breached the rules
and i think this will really boom around
the backlash will be ferocious on the
conservative party and quite rightly his
let's have a look at the front of the
metro at the sleazy way out is that is
the headline there
andrew owen patterson's argument and
those who support him is that he wasn't
given a fair hearing it's about the
fairness of the process something that's
been rumbling on for some time but i
just want to pick up on a point that
kevin made that that the conservatives
and that owen patterson will come to
regret
this and yet tonight speaking to sam
coates he's saying i would i would do
this
all over again i would act in entirely
the same manner again
well look he he says he wasn't uh uh
reaching the rules this committee said
he was 14 people seven lay all party uh
the commissioner did too uh so uh and
and i think he should have done his time
the fact is after 30 days that can
potentially trigger a recall ballot in
the constituency so if his constituents
wanted to they could demand a
by-election but you know i think there
would be huge sympathy for owen person
in his but in his constituency he's been
the mp there for a very long time he's
got a good record as an mp there and
there'd be huge sympathy for him over
the suicide of his wife the mother of
his children uh and i think he'd have
one i i don't think it would have even
come to by election but i think if there
had been one he'd have probably won it
but the the problem is even if he wasn't
given a fair hearing and that the jury's
out on that the chairman of the uh
committee chris bryant spoke very well
in the house today he wrote a couple of
articles in newspapers today making it
defending the way the committee
conducted itself uh look the the the
tories are now saying there should be a
right of appeal well there hasn't been
up until now and why are they only
demanding one now they're demanding one
now because they want owen patton to get
that appeal and a right to cross-examine
witnesses yeah it's right
but i mean he was inc he was interviewed
by the committee he was so um i'm not
quite sure how unfair the process was
but it just looks like they want to
change the rules to get an appeal in
place to save their mate that's why it
looks bad that's why there's a very
unpleasant width about this and these
can be very corrosive and very damaging
and kevin's quite right i mean what's
just these which did for john major's
government the government had been
impacted the tour has been in power for
18 years people were sick
to the tips of the back teeth of them
including me as a tory they had to go
but sleaze can be very difficult uh and
the last thing the tory party needs is
that charge of sleaze to stick because
if it's stick it'll be very hard to get
rid of it let's have a look at the
telegraph's angle on this uh kevin it is
quoting patterson who's saying that the
mp's watchdog must go
um his suspension's now on hold but what
about the standard system itself is that
now on pause
well no it's been scrapped doesn't it
the the
it's not mp's tory mps those who went
along with the three-line whip of batman
patterson or
when the prime minister said jump asked
how high have decided to scrap the
existing system and they want to to
bring in a new a new
system but labour and the smp won't play
ball with it so you'll have tory mp
sitting in in favor of touring but
if you're a dodgy business or even even
a legitimate business but you want to
hire a tory mp now's the time to do it
there we are they'll all go along about
112 000 a year is the the going rate
they'll ask questions for you the lobby
for you and and deny deny doing it's
also chaos and a complete mess the first
time this is this is this has uh
happened but there we are we have owen
patterson uh saying the standards
commissioner has to go now
the uh commons authorities are hitting
back saying no no we've got a contract
to where 2022 um
catherine stone will stay uh in until
then but the whole
we're just in politics you need right
you need mps to be most mps do beer
whatever their party they behave
including a bizarrely most but not all
of those who backed own paterson from
the conservative party they did it
either at a sympathy which i've heard
because his wife took uh
took her life the one of the companies
paying him a hundred thousand pounds a
year randox it's a diagnostic business
uh he's getting a lot of money from it
but he was found to have broken the
rules over how he represented it
approaching ministers and so on well
they also sponsor the the grand national
entry the randox grand national she is
the the chair of or was the chair of uh
avengers so you could see there would
have been ten tensions there he he's
blaming the
he's blaming the inquiry i would say
he's gonna look at his
business uh business arrangements but
yeah
there is really no system at all
now and this is just going to be
completely and utterly wrong
okay and we're going to take a short
break but coming up we are going to have
the extraordinary story of the
four-year-old girl found alive more than
two weeks after she disappeared
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh with me here are kevin
mcguire and andrew pearce so we're going
to continue our look through the papers
with the daily telegraph and uh its
headline nhs staff
won't have to be jabbed this winter a
rather different take to what the eye
says which is nhs staff are told get jab
or get out uh winter being the operative
word in the daily telegraph headline
there kevin
yeah the the discrepancy the
contradiction of the two reports which
way you look at it it's because the
health secretary sachi javad
is uh thought to be about to announce
that uh nhs staff will be required to be
jabbed but not until next april so the
telegraph take the view uh that means we
will go through the wind turn there's
about uh 90 percent uh jabbing rate in
the nhs but uh in in england with where
there's 1.2 million nhs staff that means
120 000 or so won't be there are
concentrations in various various parts
of the country where the rate is lower
than 90
and london and birmingham are
mentioned because they have a higher
proportion of uh staff from
ethnic uh heritages who are suspicious
sometimes for very good reason uh from
um from where
their parents or grandparents were
hesitant about about being jabbed so it
is an issue um but if they're going to
be moved into uh back office roles away
from frontline nhs you're going to
create huge problems uh and i would have
thought rather like the care system was
about 60 000 uh
carers thought not to have been jabbed
in the november the 11th uh cut off
there
probably much better to require that
they take daily tests than to try and uh
push them out of their jobs because
otherwise uh the nhs or the care system
which are already under considerable
pressure will just break down um
andrew i'm going to get you to talk
about the metro which is this incredible
story of um cleo smith four-year-old who
disappeared for 18 days
in australia and last night found safe
and well
it's it's just it's just so heartwarming
isn't it because um criminologists will
tell you it's unusual for a child who's
been missing that long to be reunited
with
their family this was 18 days she went
missing from a campsite they found her
the police in a house in her parents
hometown carnarvon uh a 36 year old
man's been arrested but look at her what
a great body little child there she's
with her great big lollipop her parents
um put on instagram our family's
complete the whole of australia had been
gripped by the disappearance of this
little girl the australian prime
minister has been talking about it today
how fantastic and what a great sense of
relief it is and you instantly think
don't you about madeline mccann and her
parents
um uh
that the hope that they've already a
source close to that family and said how
thrilled they are for
uh family that they found the little
girl and how it gives them great hope
that one day they may find madeline so
it's a wonderful story well done to the
police for finding her we're not quite
sure how they got tipped off that she
was in this house but she said she's
well and built in a very robust and uh
she looked like she was enjoying all the
attention
yeah and and the police themselves uh in
tears as they rescued her one very quick
word from you on this kevin before we're
out of time
yeah i know look as as andrew said he
mentioned madeleine mccann or the
parents of ben needham or countless
hundreds of thousands of children who've
been lost in
you know on the front of the the matter
of ed said back from the uh back from
the dead
parents never ever give a paul
unfortunately too many of them never
have the happy ending but this does look
like a very happy ending and you you're
just emotionally
caught up in it
yeah and and the smile on her face is
lying in that hospital bed
really wonderful to see little cleo
smith found
and returned to her parents